[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild der 9 November
1773 ist kein Tag für einen Ausflug es
ist neblig und kalt ein Wetter in dem
man sich den Tod holen kann doch alle
sind sie gekommen um zu sehen wie der
Tod sich eine von ihnen holt neben dem
Richtblock steht der Freimann der
Scharfrichter er trägt einen grellroten
Mantel mit goldenen Borden sein Gesicht
ist von einer ebenso roten Zipfelmütze
mit zwei Löchern für die Augen verdeckt
Eva kniet in einem einfachen grauen
Gewand vor dem Richtblock ein paar Meter
entfernt ragt das Rad
empor auf seinem Rand hat sich eine käe
niedergelassen als wisse sie genau dass
hier gleich ein frisches warmes mal
bereitet wird ein des freimanns schlägt
auf den Rand um sie zu
vertreiben als die fernen Glocken der
geteilten Kirche von gemünndt in knten
verklingen verließ der
landgerichtsdiener das
Urteil auf klag und Antwort red und
gegenred auch allgerichtliches an und
beibringen und der Täterin
selbsteigenbekanntnis nach ist
gesprochen worden folgendes
Urteil es solle die beim löblichen
hochgräflichen Land gut gemünndt ob
krimin venefizi in maritum kommissi
prozessierte eV Kari nach abermaliger
Bekenntnis ihres Verbrechen durch den
landesfürstlichen Freimann an der
gewöhnlichen richtstadt durch das
Schwert von Leben zum Tod hingerichtet
die rechte Hand abgeschlagen Kopf und
Hand an das Rad aufgestecket und der
Körper in
lokoslizii begraben werden zu ihrer
wohlverdienten straf anderen aber zu ein
Spiel unterzeichnet und besiegelt dr
Benedikt alphons Edler von emperger
bahnrichter es geht schnell wenigstens
geht es schnell als der Körper der Frau
in lcus suplizii der Ungeweihten Erde am
Hinrichtungsort verscharrt ist und die
Menge sich zerstreut kommt die krät
zurück landet auf dem Rand des
hochragenden Rades und betrachtet einen
Moment den Kopf und die Hand die daran
aufgespießt sind der Hingerichteten zur
straf anderern aber zu einem Beispiel
wie es im Urteil gefordert war der Vogel
weiß nichts von Schuld und Strafe ihn
kümmert nicht der Blick der toten Augen
im fahen Gesicht der Frau für ihn ist
heute ein Festtag er hat schon viel zu
lange warten müssen bis die großen
zweibeinigen Wesen mit ihren endlosen
plappereien fertig waren und endlich das
festmah zubereitet haben schnell schlägt
er seinen Schnabel in den saftigen
Augapfel Mahlzeit so begrüßt du mich
also aus dem Urlaub zurück MKO alles
klar herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem täglichen True Crime
Podcast mein Name ist Tony haer und ich
bin merko Kasimir heute erzählen wir die
tragische Geschichte der Eva Kari besser
bekannt als Eva verschauner oder Eva
verschaunerin das Ende der Geschichte
das kennt ihr ja schon tja wobei wir uns
bei der Schilderung ein bisschen
Freiheit erlaubt haben wir wissen
natürlich nicht ob es die kräe auf dem
Rad wirklich gab aber na ja wir wollen
hier auch ein bisschen Geschichten
erzählen aber keine Sorge ansonsten
bleiben wir bei den Fakten soweit sie
feststehen und da wo wir nur spekulieren
können da weisen wir euch darauf hinko
erzähl mal Eva faschauner wird am 21
Dezember 1737 in Malta geboren das hat
nichts mit der gleichnamigen Insel zu
tun sondern ist eine kleine Gemeinde in
knon im Süden Österreichs die Familie
lebt im höchstgelegenen Hof am
malterberg der faschauner Hube also
ziemlich abgelegen eva ist die jüngste
Tochter von Christian verschauner und
Maria Huber sie hat eine ältere
Schwester und zwei Brüder aber die
beiden sterben im Kleinkindalter als
auch ihre Mutter stirbt eva ist da
gerade 11 oder 12 da heiratet ihr Vater
Christian nach kurzer Zeit wieder und
Eva bekommt bald zwei kleine
Halbschwestern aber männlicher Nachwuchs
bleibt aus und natürlich war das für den
Besitzer eines Hofes vor 250 Jahren ein
riesenprem eine seiner Töchter soll den
Hof übernehmen aber das ist damals nur
denkbar wenn sie einen Mann an ihrer
Seite hat da die älteste Schwester
bereits verheiratet und weggezogen ist
soll Eva heiraten und mit ihrem Ehemann
den Hof bewirtschaften es ist die
einzige Möglichkeit das Erbe zu sichern
Eva dürfte davon nicht allzu begeistert
gewesen sein es heißt sie wolle ledig
bleiben obwohl immer wieder
heiratsfällige Männer bei ihr und ihrem
Vater anklopfen sie muss wohl ziemlich
hübsch gewesen sein und vor allem als
Erben des gutgehenden Hofes eine
verdammt gute Partie als 1770 zwei
Brautwerber im Namen eines gewissen
Jakob Kari aus untermalta bei den
faschauen vorstellich werden lehnt sie
nicht sofort ab sondern besucht schon am
nächsten Tag zusammen mit ihrem Vater
den Hof von Jakob es eigentlich sehr
verwunderlich woher jetzt dieser
Umschwung kommt also warum sie jetzt
doch heiraten will und dazu noch diesen
Jakob der galt als nah und hatte bisher
bei allen brautwerbungen ein dicken Korb
erhalten also warum sollte sich
ausgerechnet die hübsche faschaunerin
den troteligen Ladenhüter aus dem Dorf
aussuchen der Vater scheint sie nicht
gedrängt zu haben denn es gibt Berichte
nach denen er sie lieber bei sich
behalten wollte und fürchtete sie als
Arbeitskraft zu verlieren ja aber sie
war nicht nur hübsch sie war auch sehr
tüchtig und Eva scheint es mit der Angst
zu tun bekommen zu haben der Angst davor
ihr Leben als alte Jungfer auf dem Hof
zu verbringen und den dann vielleicht an
den Ehemann einer der Halbschwestern zu
verlieren aber das ist nicht ganz belegt
okay Vater und Tochter besuchen also die
Karis in untermalta
und Eva ist geschockt der Hof ist
heruntergekommen und überschuldet ein
fretten wie man sagt ein armseliges
Anwesen gar kein Vergleich zum properen
faschunerhof die ganze Familie macht auf
Eva keinen besonders guten Eindruck
Jakob selbst scheint ziemlich einfältig
und steht unter der Fuchtel von Tandel
Eva einer Verwandten die den Hof für ihn
führt seine Mutter und sein Vater sind
gestorben doch er hat noch die zweite
Frau seines Vaters an der Backe
Stiefmutter Katharina Kari die er auf
den Tod nicht ausstehen kann ja und dann
gibt es da auch noch eine ledige magt
mit einem kleinen Kind sozusagen ein
letzter Gruß vom verstorbenen Vater wenn
man das so sagen will Evas Vater ist
gegen die Ehe aber Eva hat sich warum
auch immer jetzt in den Kopf gesetzt
dass es der Jakob sein soll und sie kann
ihren Vater überreden die Schulden des
karischen Hofs zu übernehmen er
willichtt ein auch in die Hochzeit aber
die ganze Sache zerrötet das Verhältnis
zwischen den beiden nachhaltig die ganze
Ehe steht wegen der Situation auf dem
Hof und dem Streit mit dem Vater unter
gar keinem guten Stern schon am
Hochzeitstag Schein Eva Bedenken
gekommen zu sein und fast hätte sie kurz
vor dem endgültigen ja in der Kirche
einen Rückzieher gemacht tja für Jakob
den Narren ist es natürlich der
Hauptgewinn eine schöne Frau der Hof
endlich Schulden frei und irgendwann
wird auch der faschaunerhof der Familie
gehören von Anfang an haben es die magt
und Jakobs Stiefmutter Katharina auf Eva
abgesehen sie zerreißen sich im Haus und
im Dorf das Maul über die Ehe und über
die Ehefrau als Eva sich bei Jakob
darüber beschwert verspricht er die
Stiefmutter des Hauses zu verweisen doch
dazu kommt es nicht mehr 9 März 1770
vier Wochen und D Tage sind die beiden
verheiratet eva hat gekocht kartner
Nudeln nicht das was wir normalerweise
unter Nudeln verstehen also keine Pasta
sondern große gefüllte Teigtaschen eine
traditionelle Fastenspeise es hat allen
geschmeckt und das ist so ziemlich das
einzige worauf sich später alle
Beteiligten einigen können alle
Überlebenden Beteiligten sollte man an
dieser Stelle vielleicht sagen obwohl es
lecker war bleibt eine Nudel übrig die
Nudel des
Todes okay klingt wie ein Vorschlag für
ein neuen Indiana Jones Film na ja okay
wie auch immer nach dem Essen machen
sich alle wieder an die Arbeit Eva nimmt
die übrig gebliebene Nudel schneidet sie
auf und gibt sie in eine Pfanne am
Nachmittag als die Tiere gefüttert sind
kommt Jakob hungrig in die Küche Eva
verspricht ihm eine kleine Extra
Mahlzeit und brätt die übrig gebliebene
Nudel in Butterschmalz an streckt das
ganze mit Brotstücken und serviert sie
ihm also ich muss sagen wenn ich das so
hö hab ich richtig Bock auf Maultaschen
ja Tony aber ohne diese eine spezielle
Zutat du meinst genau aber dazu kommen
wir gleich dem Jakob schmeckt jedenfalls
er bietet Eva an mit zuessen wie gesagt
die Dinger konnten ziemlich groß sein
bissin zur Größe einer Faust und Eva hat
das ganze Jahr mit Schmalz und Brot noch
ordentlich gestreckt aber Eva lehnt ab
sie habe keinen besonderen Appetit sagt
sie stattdessen ist die Stiefmutter den
letzten Happen und kratzt die Pfanne
ordentlich aus da die Tagesarbeit des
Bauern erledigt ist beschließt Jakob
seinen Freund und Nachbarn den
meisterbauern zu besuchen normalerweise
bleibt er dort für eine ganze Zeit aber
an diesem Tag kehrt er schon bald nach
Hause zurück ihm ist schlecht und bald
muss er sich auch Erbrechen Eva gibt ihm
Milch und saure Milch als Hausmittel
aber er kann nichts im Magen behalten
dann wird auch der Stiefmutter übel
und schließlich auch Eva selbst so
behauptet sie zumindest die beiden
Frauen und der Bauer liegen da nieder
bei Jakob kommen Schüttelfrost und ein
unstillbares Durstgefühl dazu sein Herz
rast und kein Hausmittel will helfen vor
allem weil er es sofort wieder erbricht
am Samstag geht es Eva und der
Stiefmutter besser doch Jakobs Zustand
verschlimmert sich immer weiter am Abend
schickte Eva den Knecht zum Pfarrer da
fürchtet sie wohl schon schon das
Schlimmste bzw hofft das Schlimmste wir
werden sehen der Pfarrer erscheint er
nimmt Jakob die Beichte ab auf die
Kommunion muss er verzichten weil er
nichts bei sich behalten kann und man
wohl nicht riskieren will dass er die
Hostie wieder auskotzt pardon my
French der Pfarrer untersucht ihn wohl
auch prüft sogar den Puls und befindet
das eigentlich kein Grund zur Sorge
bestehe der Bauer habe sich nur den
Magen verdorben ja vielleicht ist es
besser wenn sich die Pfarrer um die
Seele kümmern und den Körpern anderen
also Experten
überlassen jetzt war es wahrscheinlich
schwer in einem abgelegenen Dorf in
Kärnten im Jahr 1770 einen Arzt heranz
schaffen aber es gab ja auch noch die
Bader die man sich als Mischung aus
Wunderdoktor und jahrmarktskownen
vorstellen kann wir wissen nicht ob so
einer gerade greifbar gewesen wäre und
ob er wirklich hätte helfen können oder
nur mit lesssen und was weiß ich noch
allem es nur hätte noch schlimmer
gemacht und natürlich hätte er auch
bezahlt werden müssen mm und ich meine
der Pfarrer hat sie ja beruhigt also
lassen Sie es einfach erstmal dabei am
nächsten Morgen geht es dem Bauern aber
noch schlechter trotzdem geht seine Frau
wie gewohnt zur Sonntagsmesse dort
trifft sie ihren Vater und erzählt ihm
von Jakobs Krankheit und er begleitet
sie dann mit nach Hause als sie dort
eintreffen ist deutlich dass sich der
Bauer nicht nur den Magen verringt hat
sein Körper ist
aufgedunsen Gesicht und Lippen sind blau
gefärbt doch noch immer zögert die
Bäuerin einen Bader zuufen am frühen
Sonntagnachmittag stirbt Jakob Kari der
Pfarrer der ihn am Tag zuvor zuletzt
gesehen hat notiert im Sterbebuch der
Gemeinde es starb mit dem Sakrament der
Beichte gleich wohl ohne hochheilige
sterbekommunion wegen ununterbrochenem
Erbrechen und es wurde auch keine
heilige letzte Ölung durchgeführt wegen
nichtterkennung der Todesgefahr Jakob
Kari Bauer an der hölhube in Unterdorf
im Alter von 35 Jahren bald werden die
Gerüchte
unüberhörbar ist es nicht merkwürdig
dass die frisch gebackene Witwe nicht
geweint hat und völlig ungerührt scheint
bei der Totenwache ist einigen Frauen
aus dem Dorf die blaue Gesichtsfarbe
aufgefallen einige beschwören sie hätten
des Nachts ein rumoren im Bauch des
Toten gehört als ob eine Lawine ab geht
sagen
sie na ja ich meine ganz so wild wird's
wohl nicht geklungen haben ich nehme an
dass das wohl eher irgendwelche
verdauungs oder verwesungsgase waren die
da ihr Unwesen getrieben haben Jakob
wird begraben aber die Gerüchte
verstummen nicht von Giftmord ist die
Rede von hitrach oder Hüttenrauch hier
und heute besser bekannt als Arsenik ein
Gift dessen Besitz zu jener Zeit streng
verboten ist das aber trotzdem in vielen
Bauernhöfen irgendwo im Schrank steht
ganz besonders in dieser Gegend denn nur
wenige Kilometer von Malta entfernt wird
Arsenik abgebaut und aufbereitet man
verwendet es als Medizin für das Vieh
und manchmal auch als Droge als eine Art
alpenkokain in sehr geringer Dosis
steigert es den Appetit führt zu
allgemeinem Wohlbefinden und gilt als
Stärkungsmittel wie gesagt wir sprechen
hier von sehr ringendosen und we man
vertut sich dabei in Österreich soll das
asenik Essen noch bis nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg verbreitet gewesen sein das
ist ziemlich lang schließlich laden die
Behörden im nahgelegenen gmündt Eva vor
und befragen Sie Eva streitet ab aren
ins Essen gemischt zu haben sie besäe
auch keins doch damit gibt man sich
nicht zufrieden der landgerichtsdiener
von gmünt bringt den Fall zur Anzeige
daraufhin schickt Gericht ihn und zwei
Knechte nach Malta um die Familie im
Auge zu behalten dann reist eine
Gerichtskommission an bestehend aus
einem Landrichter einem Chirurgen einem
Bader und einem Beisitzer ein Schreiber
und ein kirchenbediensteter aus Malta
ergänzen die Kommission als Einheimische
alle Beteiligten werden einzeln beim
kramerwirt in Malta befragt parallel
exumiert man den Leichnam von Jakob Kari
und obduziert ihn der Arzt stellt fest
dass die inneren Organe gesund sind nur
ein paar Entzündungen fallen ihm auf und
eine seltsame Absonderung als er die auf
gluttropfen lässt breitet sich ein
Knoblauchgeruch aus und das gilt als
sicherer Hinweis darauf dass tatsächlich
Gift im Spiel war höchstwahrscheinlich
Arsenik in der Vernehmung sagen einige
der Bewohner des Hofes aus dass dort
entgegen Evas Aussage sehr wohl Arsenik
vorhanden war um es bei viehrankheiten
oder beim Abkalben zu verwenden am
nächsten Tag bringt man Eva als
Verdächtige nach gmünndt als man sie aus
der kramerwirtschaft führt sieht sie
ihren Vater sie wirft sich auf dem Boden
ihm zu Füßen und schreit er solle sie
nicht verlassen
eV Kari geborene faschauner wird der
Prozess gemacht und der zieht sich hin
zwei Jahre sitzt Eva im Kerker und
gesteht nichts doch die Indizien
sprechen gegen Sie Eva behauptet
Stiefmutter und magt sein beim
Zubereiten der angeblich vergifteten
Nudel zugegen gewesen doch beide sagen
aus dass Eva allein in der Küche gewesen
sei Entschuldigung wir erinnern uns mal
kurz das könnte natürlich auch bedeuten
dass sich die magt und die Stiefmutter
die Eva eh nicht leiden konnten ganz
einfach zu einer Lüge verabrredet haben
des weiteren habe Eva ihren Mann und
später auch ihre Stiefmutter
aufgeforderert von der Nudel zu essen
sie selbst habe sie aber nicht angerührt
außerdem habe sie nach dem Tod ihres
Mannes teilnahmslos gewirkt und nicht
geweint ja okay ganz ehrlich ich finde
wir sollten uns hier nicht rausnehmen
darüber zu urteilen wie jemand trauert
oder eben nicht und wir wissen ja auch
dass sie nicht besonders happy in ihrer
kurzen eh war das bedeutet ja aber nicht
dass sie dann automatisch die Täterin
ist und ihn umgelegt hat vom asehen das
man im Haus findet ist ein Stückchen
abgebrochen okay aber das ist doch
absurd das kann doch jede oder jeder
gewesen sein die magt die Stiefmutter
vielleicht sogar der längst verstorbene
Vater denn man weiß ja nicht einmal wann
da etwas abgebrochen wurde da hast du
verdammt recht Tony es gab eine ganze
Reihe solcher Indizien na ja manche kann
man nicht mal Indizien nennen aber das
alles reichte selbst damals nicht für
eine Verurteilung und wenn die Beweise
nicht reichen und die Angeklagte nicht
gestehen will tja dann gibt es nur noch
eine andere Möglichkeit ich würde jetzt
gerne sagen Freispruch aber du meinst
natürlich genau am 20 Juni 1772 Eva Kari
sitzt da schon mehr als z Jahre im
Gefängnis wird der Fall an den
landesfürstlichen bahnrichter Benedikt
Alfons von emperger übertragen der nach
weiteren Vernehmungen im August bei der
landeshauptmannschaft den Antrag stellt
die Angeklagte entweder freilassen oder
sie peinlich befragen zu dürfen also zu
foltern er erhält die Genehmigung zur
peinlichen Befragung allerdings soll es
erst mit der sogenannten schreckung
versucht werden die schreckung findet am
27 Oktober
1772 statt man führt Eva Kari in die
Folterkammer wo man ihr den
Scharfrichter mit dem verhüllten Gesicht
und dem grellroten Mantel zeigt und die
Folterinstrumente die schreckung wirkt
eV g steht den mor doch als sie später
erneut befragt wird kann oder will sie
nichts darüber sagen wie und wie viel
Gift sie dem Essen beigemengt hat der
bahnrichter beantragt erneut die Folter
und bekommt erneut die Genehmigung
diesmal ohne die Einschränkung sie erst
zu schrecken am 4 februar wird sie der
Schnürung unterzogen sie sitzt auf einem
Schemel Hände und Füße sind mit dünnen
seien gefesselt diese werden von zwei
Folterknechten mit Walzen
zusammengezogen was un erträgliche
Schmerzen bereitet Eva Kari gesteht
erneut und erklärt die Tat in allen
Einzelheiten weil sie als Täterin die
Details kennt oder weil sie sich das
alles ausdenkt weil sie weiß dass es die
einzige Möglichkeit ist weiteren
Torturen zu
entgehen also echt Folter das ist ein
absurdes Konzept lassen wir mal die
ganze Unmenschlichkeit beiseite ich
meine darüber müssen wir echt nicht
reden aber das ist doch absolut kein
Instrument zur
Wahrheitsfindung ja da muss man nur an
sowas wie die Hexenprozesse im
Mittelalter denken als Menschen vor
allem Frauen die verrücktesten Dinge
gestanden haben vom buchstäblichen Ritt
auf dem Besen bis hin zu Sex mit dem
Teufel und anderem Unsinn weil sie
lieber auf dem schalterhaufen sterben
wollten als weiterhin gefoltert zu
werden lieber ein Ende mit Schrecken als
Schrecken ohne Ende zumal sie wussten
dass am Ende doch der Tod wartete ganz
egal wie lange Sie den Quälereien
widerstehen und nichts Zugaben und so
muss es auch Eva gegangen sein sie muss
inzwischen gewusst haben dass es für sie
keinen Weg zurück in die Freiheit gab
die Folter war ein Instrument um
Geständnisse zu produzieren echte oder
aus Verzweiflung erfundene ganz
offensichtlich ist es damals nicht in
erster Linie darum gegangen die wahren
Täter zu ermitteln und zu bestrafen
sondern vor allem darum tja irgendwie
ein Gleichgewicht herzustellen etwas
Schreckliches war geschehen also musste
jemand dafür bestraft werden wer und ob
ob er oder sie etwas damit zu tun hatten
das war zweitrangig und die Welt schien
wieder im Lot und die Autoritäten hatten
gezeigt dass kein Verbrechen ungesühnt
bleibt schaut her wir haben ein
Geständnis wir haben der Gerechtigkeit
Genüge getan niemand entgeht unserer
strafenden Hand und glücklicherweise
setzte sich in dieser Zeit langsam die
Erkenntnis durch das Geständnisse die
unter Folter erlangt werden absolut
wertlos sind unglücklicherweise zu
langsam für Eva Kari geborene faschauner
sie war eine der letzten vielleicht die
letzte die in Österreich aufgrund
solcher Methoden verurteilt wurde im
Jahr
1776 wurde die Folter in Österreich
abgeschafft am 20 März 1773 nach 3
Jahren im Kerker wird der faschaunerin
das Urteil verkündet wir haben es am
Anfang gehört Eva stellt ein
Gnadengesuch an Kaiserin Maria Theresia
das jedoch abgelehnt wird am 9 November
1773 stirbt sie auf der Gemünder
Richtstätte dem
galgenbichel und damit sind wir am Ende
unserer heutigen Geschichte danke dass
ihr heute mit dabei wart und dass ihr
auch hoffentlich nächstes Mal wieder mit
einschaltet eure Tony und euer Mirko
unsere wichtigste Quelle für diese Folge
waren verschiedene Beiträge in der
cararinia vor allem aus den Jahren 1958
und
1964 die über die Website der
österreichischen national Bibliothek
verfügbar sind die Links dazu haben wir
in der Wikipedia gefunden deren sehr
guter und umfangreicher Artikel einen
guten und detailreichen Überblick über
den Fall
bietet dir hat diese Folge von tout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei tatau
Deutschland